wright announced recently that they'll
begin to record voice comms and valor to
help train ai to combat toxicity for
some people toxicity is just an
unavoidable problem in video games but
is riot taking a step too far to help
keep the balanced streets clean
let's talk about it
i know it's been a while since i've been
here with y'all on doing at me but i am
back but you also might have noticed
there have been a bunch of changes to my
studio that's because we partnered with
our friends over at elgato they sent me
a bunch of stuff and upgraded a bunch of
my equipment including this new mic arm
that doesn't creak and make lots of
noise just is the worst maneuver like my
last one so a huge thank you and shout
out to them while i was watch partying
the vct riot was cooking a little
something up for us valerian scrubs if
you've played valorent or any video game
you might have been on the receiving end
of some conversations that were
annoyingly rude or incredibly
problematic and i'm sure you've only
been on the receiving end because you
guys would never ever be toxic right not
my the score esports viewers regardless
if you've been on the receiving or
hypothetically dispensing end riot has
seen and heard enough wright announced
that starting july 13th they'll begin a
background launch of the voice
evaluation system in north america slash
english only help train our language
models and get the tech in a good enough
place for a beta launch this year to put
it simply they're going to be listening
to players voice comms to help train
their ai to accurately detect toxicity
now this is ringing any bells riot has
talked about this before all the way
back in april 30th 2021 a month before i
graduated college riot talked about
updating their privacy policy for this
exact reason you know the privacy policy
the thing you pretend to read with
literally everything you sign up for
anyways riot wrote that and bear with me
on this this is a long one quote the
update to our privacy notice allows us
to record and potentially evaluate voice
data when using riot owned voice comms
channels when a player submits a report
for disruptive or offensive behavior and
voice comms the relevant audio data will
be stored in your account's registered
region and evaluated to see if our
behavior agreement was violated if a
violation is detected we'll take action
after the data has been made available
to the player in violation and is no
longer needed for reviews the data will
be deleted similar to how we currently
handle text-based chat reports no
violation is detected or if no report is
filed in a timely manner the data will
be deleted one important thing to note
is that other riot titles essentially
everything related to league of legends
does not have any plans to adopt
something like this a little more
recently back in february riot talked in
depth about toxicity and ballerin and
what they've been doing to combat it
part of their system has always relied
on player reports i'm sure you've all
been in games where the enemy team types
something in all chat asking you to
report a specific player now sometimes
it's a joke because they whipped on a
clutch and you see an all chat report
our jet for throwing but sometimes it's
because they are hurling slurs at their
team these reports are desired by rye
because they say they actively track and
use that data to administer punishments
all of us have comms rating so that if
we are notorious bad guys in the server
they know that and they can deal with us
i'm sure all of us have reported someone
for toxicity but sometimes i wonder when
i see player feedback received and
someone was punished
why my other reports didn't get someone
punished riot made it clear that not
everyone who gets reported gets punished
because that would be prime grounds for
trolls but they look for repeat
offenders then there's also the zero
tolerance policy that has been in place
which is essentially one strike and then
after that match you're out muted words
are their next line of defense you
manually put in which you don't want to
see which they said they plan on using
in the quote automatic detection in
future iterations of the system they go
into talking about chat mute and how
restrictions bans have been issued and
talk about how they want in the future
to include harsher punishments real-time
tax moderations voice moderation and the
turkish zero tolerance program alarmbot
yeah you heard me right real-time text
moderation and real-time zero-tolerance
ejections what does this have to do with
recording our voice columns well
valerian is toxic and water is wet more
news at 11. i am pretty confident when i
say that almost everyone watching this
video has dealt with something that has
been harmful and if you're one of those
people that says i've never dealt with
toxic people or y'all never would have
survived cod lobbies back in my day take
a quick look in the mirror babe i'll
wait
but in order to deal with the problem
that has been brought up again and again
and again raya is going to take the step
to record voice comms unfortunately we
have reached a point where riot believes
further steps need to be taken in order
to make the game enjoyable because what
this looks like is that plain old
reports that we had been using aren't
the best option anymore or at least
aren't working as well as they'd hoped
now there have been concerns about
privacy this is kind of a giant data
thing and like this reddit user brought
up speaking about riot and how they
could use the comms to create data
profiles and use the comms for
commercial purposes a lead designer for
one of the teams responded to this by
saying you're right that there's a lot
of interesting things you could do in
theory with this data but ultimately
we're not in that business making a
business out of player data puts that at
risk and of course is super icky without
consent and if i'm being honest a little
icky to me even with consent i expect i
would almost certainly lose my job if i
tried to push for us to do what you're
describing rightfully so as it wouldn't
be the right mentality for what we do we
really do just want to make ballerina a
safer and more pleasant experience here
personally as a woman yes i'm using that
card right your angry comments now i
would like to feel safe in the community
of a game that i play enjoy and have
elected to make my life's work however
do i like the idea of my voice being
recorded and used for a bot
i honestly don't know what price am i
willing to pay for safety and sanity a
complete or even partial lack of privacy
i don't know the answer to that yet then
there's that conspiracy part of me that
thinks well what's next well i'm
inclined to believe that designer from
reddit i'm also no fool
by no means trying to say right we'll
sell our data but hypothetically if they
did in the future
they would not be the first company to
do so all of this being said am i being
a bit hypocritical and saying all this
while talking about the game that has
vanguard as part of the deal for
downloading it there are very few
cheaters in ballerin and it's because of
vanguard literally sitting there while i
play genji impact or literally do
anything else it's that kernel level
access that system is called vanguard it
downloads with valrant asks you to
restart your computer and then runs on
startup from then on out even when
you're not playing battery this thing is
just always chugging along in the
background and for some people that's
pretty unsettling there's been a lot of
backlash about just how intrusive this
program is and whether or not that level
of invasiveness is necessary in an
anti-cheat program people all over the
internet have been calling this a breach
of privacy and many are looking at riot
and tencent the company that owns them
in china who are also very close with
the chinese government and questioning
their motives that is also a breach of
privacy in my opinion yeah i may not be
collecting any data but it's still just
sitting there while i do anything else
but i still play valerian every single
night regardless this is the solution
ride has come up with and honestly it
goes farther than i thought any studio
would go to keep their community clean
how successful it will be and will other
studios follow suit well that all
remains to be seen we have less than a
week until this is implemented until
valorent changes forever and there's no
more toxicity yeah well a girl can hope
until then as i'm sure you already do
keep it clean and keep it fun
it's literally just a game
hear me out what if on the date when
this is implemented we just start all
speaking in asmr where it's like welcome
back to my
there's this welcome back to my
followers
heart push b
like you're just ridiculous in the bi or
like whoever is like they're working
with the boss just like
huh